We would like to now apply
the momentum principle
to examples of recoil.
So recall that the
momentum principle
is that the external
force causes the momentum
of the system to change.
Now, this is a vector equation.
So for example, if the external
force in the x direction
is 0, then the momentum of
the system in the x direction,
let's say, the final
momentum will be
equal to the initial momentum.
I would like to now apply
the momentum principle
to an example of recoil.
In our recoil example, we have
a person jumping off a cart.
So let's just look at
how this example can work
if we draw momentum diagrams.
So suppose we choose
a ground frame.
And in that ground frame,
we have a cart and a person.
A person is standing
on the cart.
And this is t initial.
And here, they are at rest.
Now, the person we're going
to assume to jump horizontally
off the cart, and
the cart will recoil
in the opposite direction.
So after the jump, we can
describe this picture.
The person is moving
with the velocity,
v. The cart is moving with vc.
And the person has jumped
with the velocity vp.
Now, suppose I choose a
different reference frame.
That instead of
choosing a ground
frame, as a reference frame
moving with the velocity vc.
You can imagine that
maybe I have a car here
and you're inside that car
moving with velocity vc,
and you're looking
at this picture.
Then, what would our
momentum diagrams look like?
Well, if I'm moving
in a car this way
and in the ground frame
the initial picture
is the person in
the cart is at rest.
Then, in my moving
frame, it actually
looks as if the
cart and the person
are moving in the
opposite direction.
So let's write that this way.
Here's the initial
picture, t initial.
And in this frame, the
person and the cart
are moving with vc minus vc.
I put an arrow here
to indicate that it's
opposite the
direction of vc there.
But their velocity
is minus the velocity
of the reference frame.
After the jump-- so
here's the person now.
The cart is at rest, why?
Because we're in the reference
frame moving with vc.
So if you're in a car and
you're moving at the same speed
that the cart has
with the ground frame,
then in your frame, this
cart looks like it's at rest.
What about the
person jumping off?
Well, let's write it this way.
So this is the velocity.
I'm going to use a symbol, u.
Now, u-- this is what
do we mean by that.
This is the velocity of
the person in the moving
frame that's moving with
velocity vc-- that's
the velocity of the
person as seen by a car.
Sometimes we call this
the velocity of the person
relative to the cart.
What does that word
relative to the cart mean?
Well, you can see
in this picture.
In this moving frame,
the cart is at rest,
and the person jumps
with the speed u velocity
u relative to the cart.
So these are momentum
diagrams for a ground frame
in which the person
in the cart started
at rest, the person jumps off.
I can put an arrow
here, but it's really
information is in that vector.
The cart is moving.
In a frame moving with
the velocity of the cart,
then what does my
picture looks like?
Well, the cart and
the person initially
are moving opposite directions.
Again, you're moving this way.
The cart looks like
it's moving that way
if you're inside the car.
And the final state,
person, cart is at rest
and the person is jumping
with the velocity u
relative to the cart.
Now, our question now
is how do we relate
these two velocities, u and vp?
What are u and vp?
vp is the velocity of the
person in the ground frame.
And u is the velocity of the
person in the moving frame.
Well, we've already
seen our equation
for how to get velocities
in different frames.
We have that vp equals the
relative velocity of the two
frames plus the velocity
in the moving frame.
So what we have is, this is
the velocity of the person--
let me just clean that up-- of
the person in the ground frame.
v is the relative velocity
of the two frames.
So here we have that v is
the velocity of the cart,
because you're in a frame
moving with vc with respect
to the ground.
And u is the velocity of the
person in the moving frame.
So this is how we can show
the same type of interaction
in two different
reference frames.
Next, we'll figure out
what these velocities are.